over time so if you are a speaker you
should remember to protect the next
speaker from being okay from the
blockchain we are we starting from
Genesis back again so I like to
introduce Qian Qian graduate students at
MIT thank you for the introduction link
and thank you too doll yelling for the
invitation to present here this is
currently still ongoing work with Ted
shreya and they had a rule at MIT to
show currency initiative so this project
got started while I was doing a summer
internship at the MIT DCI and we're
hoping to put this up our kyv and eprint
sometime late November to early December
so today I'm going to be talking about
adaptive adversaries in block consensus
and using VDS to come back leader
corruption so this was actually very
good scheduling on the part of the
organizers because the model that I'm
going to be talking about will be the
exact same model that Rafael talked
about in the previous talk so a lot of
the slides will be overlapping which
means that I'll be skipping through some
of the slides if they were talked about
a lot in the previous presentation so
again the goal of large cell consensus
is there are millions of participants we
can't have all of these can participate
send messages because that will flood
the network so a reasonable goal a
reasonable goal for us to have is we
want sublinear number of messages or a
multi is messages or multicast so
sub-quadratic total number of messages
sent and sub linear multicasts where
multicast is defined as a replica
sending a message to all nodes in the
network what this translates to is we
also want poly logarithmic number of
rounds and multi sub linear multicast
complexity immediately implies that not
everyone in the network will get to
speak
during iteration of the protocol we also
want our protocol to be robust against
strong adversaries so let's talk well
Center on the definition of strong
adversary so I'll actually describe what
I mean by strong a bazaar you later and
we also want to avoid energy wasting
proof of work so proof of work these
days when you go down to the very very
core is you want to compete some hash
and because the computation of hash
values is easily parallelizable what
proof of work has dissolved into is a
race to build better Asics that can
compute these hashes in parallel and
this has led to a very energy-intensive
type of computation so we want to avoid
this in our protocols
so the idea the key idea how to avoid
this comes from this very nice work by
channa miquellee called Algren which I'm
sure all you have heard of and the idea
is you want to elect a small usually
poly logarithmic size community or a
committee this is called cryptographic
sortition and then run a more or less
traditional consensus protocol on this
committee which votes of course it's not
exactly a traditional there exists other
tweaks you need to do in the protocol I
see the partition oh I see I think the
cryptograph result Rishon the term might
have been introduced by the speaker but
yes I agree there is a lot of previous
papers which this paper builds upon so
thanks for pointing that out
yeah so um now I'm going to talk about
adversaries and consensus which
basically this algorithm was built to
try to combat and so let me just start
with what traditional adversaries are
like in consensus so traditional
adversaries for consensus introduced in
1980s and 1990s basically have static
adversaries meaning you have a set of
replicas before the iteration of the
protocol is run the adversary chooses a
set of replicas to corrupt and become
Byzantine and basically Byzantine notes
don't have to follow the protocol which
means that they can choose to send
arbitrarily member of messages do
whatever they want so after you select
these Byzantine adversaries and is
usually 1/3 for partially synchronous
and 1/2 of synchronous you run the
consensus protocol because this is
protocol then agrees on some number of
values in your log
for dr. Baba serious version is also
mentioned in Rafael's talk we want to
look at adversaries which can choose
these set of Byzantine nodes adaptively
depending on what your protocol does so
the rationale for this is consensus
nowadays are used for managing billions
of dollars so there's an incentive for
adversaries to be smarter and be better
in terms of corrupting this consensus
protocol so you know that we have a
certain model initially before the
protocol is run you can corrupt a few
notes or you can choose to corrupt
no notes at all so everybody could start
off honest if they obviously wants
everybody to start up honest then you
run the protocol at some particular step
in the protocol the adversary could
decide oh there's a key player in the
protocol let me rub that player right
now so immediately after some step or
immediately before some step of the
protocol the adversary can say I'm going
to corrupt this key player in the
protocol and they corrupt this player so
they can do this repeatedly they don't
have to corrupt their fraction of
Byzantine notes immediately they can
choose to wait some number of steps
before they corrupt in other replicas so
even though they can corrupt adaptively
there's still some bound on the total
number of replicas they can corrupt and
also once a replica is corrupted it
stays corrupted for the duration of this
iteration of the protocol so it seems
like we're giving the adversary a very
strong role in this in corrupting this
protocol but in fact this can model a
number of real-life situations for
example you can bribe a certain player a
certain crucial player in the protocol
you can also selectively pull together
all your resources and DDoS a very
important player at this particular time
and you can also pull together all your
resources the hacker
so these are a number of situations
which could allow somebody to be
adaptive and corrupt a key player at
some point
okay so here are some ways the adaptive
adversary can leverage their
adaptiveness to mess with the protocol
so if you have a first of all if you
have a predictable leader schedule you
can corrupt the leader before they are
elected if everybody in the protocol can
say who's gonna be the next leader you
can just corrupt the leader before they
become elected and then once they become
elected because you have a predictable
leader schedule they will just prevent
liveness meaning preventing the protocol
from making progress even if you have a
random leader schedule you can corrupt
the leader right after they're elected
which means that afterwards you can
flood the network with many junk
proposals or a conflicting proposal
again violating liveness here if you
have a committee if you have a small
Poli logarithmic committee the adversary
also has enough budget to corrupt the
entire committee so after you crop the
committee
you can send votes for every proposal
because your business keynote you can
vote for whatever you want you can
potentially send votes for every
proposal violating safe safety or
selectively said votes to certain honest
members and not others and making people
think that they have different logs of
committed transactions so these are some
of the ways adaptive adversaries can
mess with the protocol
so our and solves all these problems
using the following methods they
introduced this cryptographic sortition
which has been mentioned in various
other presentations before me basically
you cannot predict the set of leaders or
committee members are your children
ahead of time they also introduced clear
with pin stability which means I each
leader or committee only gets to speak
once and it only gets to do one role in
the protocol before they're replaced
again yes okay but thanks thank you for
pointing out that so this is described
in many of our grants works however they
also need to assume this key erasure
model to deal with the second type the
second two types of attacks I mentioned
in the previous slide so again what is
this key razor model the model states
that cheese can be raised at will
arbitrarily from a replica storage
without recovery possibilities so as
Raphael mentioned in his previous talks
there's many possible reasons why this
might not be feasible in the real world
this could include hardware failures so
the hard way just fails to erase the key
or the harbor could have fault-tolerant
backups meaning that you think that the
hardware you raised the key from some
part of the hardware but he could it
could have actually saved the key
somewhere else to deal with fault
tolerance or there could be human errors
the program could have just had a error
or a had a flaw in his cold and fail to
be a key so there are the possibilities
and
also as Raphael mentioned there's
provincial bribing involved with respect
to having people save their keys and
somebody selling somebody buying these
keys and potentially launching a
long-range attack so it's always
interesting to explore alternatives to
kiri sure because of these three
possible reasons why they it it is hard
to implement it in the real world so the
rest of this talk will be focusing on
exploring alternatives to key rager to
solve the problem of corrupting leaders
and committees members after election
[Music]
Mikey oh my secret it's me and if I
raise it myself I mean the idea is you
want to erase the keys it's just so if
somebody corrupts you they can't keep
voting as you so basically if you raise
the key after you perform your action
you're not allowed to perform more
actions for that step and that's the
whole protection against somebody
corrupting you after you became leader
or somebody corrupting you after you
became a committee member from doing a
bunch of things like sending out junk
proposals or sending out junk votes and
such yeah so it is it is a way to erase
yourself just so you can protect
yourself against the adversary who might
control you
okay so um one of the works that seeks
to deal with this not using the curator
assumption or the Kyrie's your model is
a a work on binary Byzantine agreement
so I'm gonna quickly define what binary
business agreement is so binary
Byzantine agreement is all nodes are
given a bit as input you must agree on
the bit zero or one if all honest notes
start with one bit as inputs say they
all start with one then you must agree
on one so recently a work by some number
of people in this room and others use
volt specific eligibility instead of the
razor model to determine the volts for
binary Byzantine Bremen so here you mine
a volt by passing into the argument one
or zero and the round number and then
the honest replicas this is very
important the honest replicas only tried
to mine one of the votes so one or zero
so the way that this provides security
is that even if a voter so somebody who
attempted to mine a vote gets corrupted
and tries to mine for the other bit it
will be hard for them and with high
probability cannot mine enough votes for
the other bit so this was also mentioned
the previous talk so like so for in the
interest of time I refer you to the
three B's talk for the analysis so a
natural extension of this is to also
pass in the block not just a bit so if
you want to extend that technique to
general block consensus we say it's not
passing in the bit 1 or 0 we pass in the
entire block so as mentioned it
emphasized in previous presentation this
results in a grinding issue and I just
want to emphasize this again because
this is also important for my
presentation so with this protocol the
adversarial strategy would be to create
an arbitrarily large number of
transactions to attempt to create a
block that obtains disproportionate
number of adversarial volts so what this
essentially means is that you grind
through many blocks in an attempt to
make sure that your your business
notes get a disproportionate number of
votes for that block so by the turnout
bound if you assume the committee's size
is lambda the probability that this
happens on any particular block is
approximately e to the negative Omega
epsilon squared lambda so let's suppose
the adversary we have an ideal adversary
and somehow the person choosing the
committee set the committee size log in
and epsilon is constant then the
adversary the very ideal emissary needs
only grind through all n messages to
obtain one an expectation so that a
majority of the adversaries control the
votes for that block so again this is
the ideal adversary but if we assume
they are model that an adversary can
grind through arbitrarily large number
of finite messages they can do this
regardless of what the probability of
failure is so what this essentially
means is that we have dissolve this
problem into a proof-of-work which means
that you can do this grinding of
messages in parallel and a person or an
adversary who has more computation power
is able to grind for greater number of
adversarial volts so as Raphael
mentioned consensus for hurting solve
this problem by assigning scores
transactions by age and then bashing
together the transactions so and also
the main part is they hash the batch to
a smaller sample space so you can't
grind through as many big messages so
you still have some grinding but it's
not enough of effect to get the result
that you want
but a strategy for their protocol and a
bizarre-o strategy for their protocol is
to flood the network with a bunch of
adversarial transactions what does this
mean if you flood the network with a
bunch of out of serial transactions then
you will have a bunch of average so
transactions which become old
transactions and therefore will have a
greater weight of the score put on the
those transactions so what this
essentially impacts is block size as
well as block quality so if we care
about block quality meaning a large
number of transactions should be honest
transactions instead of adversarial
transactions if you use this batch
strategy you'll basically get every
single adversarial transaction in a
block if you want to somehow avoid this
you need to do you do something in
addition
so to a rotary of the to reiterate the
problems that we want to solve with our
protocol we want to propose something
that doesn't use a key erasure model and
we also want to ensure some quality
measure of the block as opposed to just
having all adversarial transactions be
committed
so the intuition we we use to solve this
problem is that each block proposal
takes some number of time steps even if
somebody has a parallel computer you
still have to take this number of time
steps to to compute some proof of the
proposal and it would be impossible to
propose to different messages before the
next round occurs because you have to
take this many time steps to compute
some proof of the proposal so intuition
is as ROM mentioned in the previous
during the previous presentation it's
that we want you to somehow commit to
our block before we send it and this is
a form of commitment that is very
distinct from proof of work it's just a
commitment that you have to spend some
number of steps before you're able to
propose a block so what do I exactly
mean and now I will explain what I
exactly what know what I mean exactly so
we're dealing here with the synchronous
model so the sequence model has been
summarized again again in the previous
presentations I won't summarize it again
but just as a note our protocol will be
operating in the synchronous model
so now we use this primitive this
recently constructive primitive called
a verifiable delay function and the
verifiability function is a function
that takes some input as well as a
difficulty parameter so the difficulty
parameter as I denoted here D is the
time it takes to compute the function
even on a parallel computer so
parallelization and it shouldn't help
you here but once you compute it the
output and the proof the output can be
easily verified and verified in a short
amount of time
so formally you have this function that
takes a security parameter gamma a
difficulty parameter D the time that is
necessary for it to run before it gets
the output input X and an output Y and
approve and with some you have to do
some security setup to obtain this
function so yeah why is that I'll put
PI's approval there exists a verify
function that taken taking in the input
the output as well as a proof determines
whether the input the outputs that is
inputted into this verify function is
the correct output given the the input X
and this verify function can be run in
logarithmic time of the D value the
difficulty value so you can verify
quickly again the replication is quick
so I want to emphasize some properties
of VDS that we use in our protocol the
first property is the honest party takes
approximately the same amount of time to
compute the vdf so no more than 1 plus
epsilon D time for some small epsilon
depending on setup
this property called adversary secret
reality is basically saying a parallel
adversarial algorithm cannot compute the
solution in less than d time and
uniqueness an adversarial algorithm
cannot compute a solution that is not
equal to the intended output and what I
say cannot hear everything when I think
not I mean with negligible probability
so everything everything the setting is
with high probability sitting so both of
these cannot you can interpret it as
with negligible probability they can do
the following
and it takes old log d verification time
where DS difficulty parameter
so now I will describe our protocol so
our protocol first of all assumes around
ve F where each replica per compute the
output from the VD f continuously if it
is the first honest replica to compute
the output then in most high castes it
to all other are replicas so this VD f
takes time D so what I mean by compute
this VD f continuously is that it takes
the output of the previous video F
computation and passes in to the next
video of computation and all the honest
replicas have the same copy of the video
so that even if a honest replica chooses
not to compute this video output for
around they will be able to obtain it
and check it from another replica who
will has computed this output for this
round and has multi Kassadin as well as
proof and we use this to delineate Ralph
so the rounds are these red lines which
are unfortunately a bit hard to see and
we say that round L starts from when
role L which is the output of the video
is computed and sent to everybody to
when the next output of the round vdf is
computed
so using this we can perform leader
election
so in leader reaction we first randomly
decide if a leader using this output
from the round vdf so we randomly just
determine the leader using the vrf
construction which is similar to the
leader election from albarran it's just
a simple computation and then once the
replica has decided that is the leader
it computes a separate message vdf
output so each replica artist replica as
well as a material replica has its own
individual video function and it takes
into this video function the output of
the random selection of whether is
leader as well as the block that he
wants to send out so once it determined
whether is a leader it puts in to other
vdf the output of this vrf say output as
well as a block
so this vdf has difficulty minus 2
epsilon minus 2 log d
so once it has finished computing the
result of this message vdf it will then
multicast the resultant message vdf the
proof of the result of this message vdf
the proof that it was indeed leader as
well as a block
so now we we use vote based eligibility
to determine voting on this block that
this proposer has proposed so upon
receiving some proposal so again this is
the same format as the proposal that was
sent here you determine whether you can
vote on the proposal via vote based
committee selection on the block that
was proposed
and if is if you successfully mind of
all your most most high caste to
everybody the vote on this block and the
proof that you can vote on it so if we
use a vrf in this first step then the
proof of the work a proof of the vote
would just be the proof of the Veera
output so this is basically the same
vote based eligibility as was used in
herding and also in binary Byzantine
agreement
and finally we must be able to commit a
block so to convey the block after we
see him in 2/3 majority of votes
assuming poly log sighs committees for
30 consecutive rounds so the key here is
the Browns must be consecutive
so three consecutive rounds you confirm
the block and this proof was inspired by
hostile commitment scheme but it's also
very similar to a lot of the standard
commitment schemes used in these types
of protocols
so I want to conclude this talk with
some emphasis on the safety measures of
our protocol so we we protect against
leader corruption after the election
because you can any say leader who
determine that they were a leader and
mind the first proposed block does not
have enough time to compute the other
block before the next round starts
you cannot mine another vote for a
different block even if you corrupt the
committee because no move no more than
one block exists in expectation
and with overwhelming probability in
poly logarithmic round you have at least
one set of C over three equals three
rounds which will have three
consecutively honest proposals and
committees so you'll be able to commit a
block any Polliwog rounds to a
termination of protocol and assuming
Committees of poly logarithmic size you
get a message complexity of law n times
poly log and round this there should be
poly log this is a typo here so it
should be message complexity all of n
times poly log and message complexity or
a poly log multicast complexity
so before I conclude ah I want to put in
a plug for the crypto economics systems
journal so nee hi is a director of this
journal and is currently receiving some
number of submissions and stood next
week and Dahlia is also on the board of
this journal so quick plug and let me go
back to this our final I'm happy to take
questions now so when we say music class
group and also the follow-up question of
this is that approval has to be
reasonably efficient such that when you
get there so for our protocol let me
just answer the second question first so
far protocol we can actually handles up
to some constant factor of difference
between how fast the adversary can
compute the video versus how fast the
oddest party can complete the vdf yes so
we have we can handle up to some some
constant it's just the protocol I showed
here is a very very simplified overview
protocol but in are more complex groups
to go head off to some constant with
respect to the initial secure setup we
just assume the existence of some
security setup from the vdf because we
use a sort of like a black box
construction
yeah do you have a separate you have
like BDSM I there is that separate
public parameters separate set up for
every participant it doesn't have to be
I presented it as a separate set up with
just for clarity that we want each
individual person to compute their own
message because you have no incentive to
compute message as a father but it
doesn't have to be so improves our in
terms of two halves the question was
whether we can do safety for half safety
and aliveness for half yourself to Thurs
so our proofs are in terms of two thirds
mainly our commitment because we we use
similar with techniques as to previous
papers perhaps but they were part of
using these rules is that it's difficult
or impossible to get to exactly one
liter you can even go to if your case
there would be no - if round after round
around there are two liters
oh so that's a branching that's the that
will resolves from branching so well
this is exactly why we need three
consecutive rounds so that we we assume
that if we allow for three consecutive
rounds after poly logarithmic say times
a particular round of this protocol is
run you'll get three consecutive rounds
in which a unique leader was elected and
also the committee was honest so if you
get to if you get two leaders proposing
to different blocks your votes will be
split and you just won't make progress
on that around but then you'll get out
of their leader and in poly algorithms
make rounds with high probability you'll
probably get 3 3 consecutive rounds in
which you can commit yeah
yes I have a question about a into
cooking levels of the VBA yes leaders
electorate vdf obvious election it's vdf
for we are VRS committee reactions are
vrf we don't use a vdf at all for the
committee election yeah only leader you
oh yeah is leader election is only based
on vrf so there we don't use a video we
only use the round video output for
committee for leader election after you
get elected you use a vdf to basically
commit to your message
[Applause]